Ben when Matt Damon he's been here and
he talked about the night you won the
Oscar for Good Will Hunting and he has a
kind of particular take on it yeah I
don't look very happy in that particular
photograph it really was he looks at
looks drunk but I wasn't looking back do
you gotta rejoice that you had that
amazing success so early on or does a
bit of you kind of not regret it but
sort of I don't know think was a bit of
a curse I mean I don't think it was a
curse but I couldn't really appreciate
it I mean who was very hallucinatory it
was like I don't know if I've ever been
a traffic accident but there's that
moment where you go my god I'm gonna
crash into this wall over here you know
everything sort of slows down and you're
spinning around that was how it kind of
felt they said our names and sort of
looked at man and was like should we get
up and we get up and there's you know
people are clapping there you know and
there was a Jack Lemmon and Walter
Matthau presented it to us and you know
Billy Crystal was hosting and he was
going back and been mad and you know I
was 24 years old I mean I barely knew
anything at all and and it was you know
I mean I think it was in some ways
trouble to get that much attention that
young and I really didn't have any
perspective on it at all it was a
wonderful honor but it was a you know I
certainly appreciated later on much more
what it meant and was there a kind of
thing where people thought you were that
character yeah I think people thought
that Matt was the math genius and I was
his sort of dim-witted friend he dragged
along from home you give him an Oscar to
stayed with me for a while you're
alright - you can go ahead so be back at
the Oscar podium Fargo that must have
been such a kind of what a satisfying I
hope no one thought it was a dim-witted
friend anyway I don't ya know that was
it was it was much more satisfying and I
had been through so much stuff so many
ups and downs and humiliations and highs
and lows and and you know at that point
I had had had three children and I had
built a whole life and it felt like
something that was much more I
appreciate it and I really felt like I
also knew what it meant it when it
didn't mean you know what I mean and
that what was important about it and
what wasn't and and it was a really nice
night and I got to share with people
that I really loved and it was probably
a much more healthy I have to go with
this little ritual where I go out I give
the guy $20 to do like a pantomime
kung-fu Adam West fight me some like
lines sure sure sure
if you